Dới chứ kìa tiền độ ngày 20 xo tăng một khẳng định virus niềm, không buồn phát chỉ dự giọt,
chứ biết tình hình hiện vẫn được kìm suá và mới dình hận 2 các nhiễm tại bang, tay bánh gồn.
Theo các quán này tự điệu phương, các trường hợp niềm được nếu vào điều trị và sét nghiệm đều cho cái quảm tính,
chưa phát hiện thêm chủ ở lệnh nghiệm mới, khoảng 50% chí mi người tiếp xúc gần để được khoanh gồm theo dõi và cất liy theo cuối trình phòng dịch.
Nhà chí chết cho biết các biển pháp giám xác, truy vét và sét nghiệm được chiến khai kìa thời,
hóa phần nụn định tình hình và hạn chế quyết cơ lệnh trăm cộng đồng.
Tuy nhiên, bây giờ sỏi vẫn được duy chiến dốt thời sán ua bản của virus niềm và có thể kéo dài từ văn ngày, đến hơn một tháng.
virus niềm sẽ là buồn đi giọa ít em nghiêm trọng, gió tỉ lệ tự vong cao, và hiện chủ có vắc xin 2 tuần được chỉ đặc hiệu.
Dù vảy giới chuyên môn nhận định, loại virus này khó lệnh giện dọt chủ thời gian ám.
Đến này, bên năm chưa khi nhận chủ việc virus niềm.